نحييكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره
للاحداث في السودان منذ تفجر الازمه التي
بدات بعد الحشد العسكري الذي نفدته قوات
الدعم السريع قرب مطار مروي العسكري في
الولايه الشماليه بدات التساؤلات تطفو الى
السطح حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا التوتر
المتابع
مشاهدينا نتابع مع بعض الاخبار ذات الصله
في اخر هذه التطورات انقطاع البث عن
التلفزيون الرسميه السوداني كذلك تواصل
الاشتباكات رغم اعلان الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع فتحه مسارات امنه كنا نتحدث
عن
اقتراح اممي بفتح مسارات امنه لمده اربعه
ساعات ابتداء من ساعه من الان تقريبا
بالتوقيت المحلي في السودان ولكن كان هناك
اطلاق نار مما استوقف البعض المفروض كانت
هناك اربع ساعات لوقف اطلاق النار لتمكين
كذلك المدنيين من الخروج في هذا الاطار
مشاهدينا وفي بعض الاخبار ذات الصله كانت
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما اجرى اتصالا اخر مع نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده محمد حمدان ديجلو واكد وزير
الخ ضروره تهدئه ووقف كل اشكال التصعيد
العسكري بما يحافظ على مقدرات السودان كما
شدد الامير فيصل بن فرحان على اهميه
العوده الى الاتفاق الايطاليه الذي يضمن
تحقيق الامن للسوداني
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
التوتر لا يزال سيد الموقف في السودان
خيوط الخلافات بين مكونين عسكري ومدني
فتحت باب التساؤل حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا
التوتر وتقود في نهايتها لمارس الماضي
وخلاف ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
الورشه التي اختتمت حينها وسط تغيب بقاده
الجيش شهدت خلافات النشبت بين ضباط الجيش
المشاركين في ختام ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وقاده قوات الدعم السريع ابرز
نقاط الخلاف كان صياغه التوصيات الاخيره
للورشه التي تتطرق لاصلاحات امنيه ابرزها
مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش
وتواريخ الدمج وتفاصيل الرتب حيث طالبت
ورقه الجيش بحصر دمج قوات الدعم السريع
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه التي حددها
الاتفاق الايطالي باربعه وعشرين شهرا ووضع
ترتيبات امنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقعه
على اتفاق جوبا لسلام السودان وفق جدا
محدده كما تحدد ورقه الجيش ضوابط ومعايير
قبول التحاق ضباط قوات الدعم السريع وتسرح
من تم تعيينهم بعد سقوط نظام الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير وتقنين صلاحيات الدعم
السريع العسكريه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه من
جهه اخرى الخلاف بين الدعم السريع والجيش
ليس خلافا فنيا حول فتره دمج قوات الدعم
السريع والتي تطالب الاخيره بان تكون خلال
عشر سنوات بل هو خلاف سياسي بسبب تقاطع
مواقف قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حميدتي
تجاه العمليه السياسيه والتحالفات
المستقبليه خاصه ان الدعم السريع نص
بتوصياته خلال ورشه الاصلاح الامني على
مراجعه وتطوير العقيده العسكريه وناي
المؤسسه العسكريه عن التدخل في السياسه
لكن الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين العسكريتين
اعمق من مجرد اختلاف على عمليه دمج القوات
فمصادر مقربه من البرهان ودجلو كشفت
بانهما ما زال على خلاف حول من سيتقلد
منصب القائد العام للجيش خلال فتره
الاندماج التي ستمتد عده سنوات
شكرا لحضورك وفي اخر التطورات نشير الى
هذا العاجل قبل متابعه ورصد الاوضاع
الميدانيه فداخل السوداني رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي يقول انه سيتوجه الى
السودان فورا اذا رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي يقول انه سيتوجه الى السودان
فورا نبدا او نستمر بالاحرى برصد الاوضاع
الميدانيه من الخرطوم ورسول العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا التوقيت او
فقدنا الاتصال بسالم طيب فقدنا الاتصال
بزميلنا سلمى الهاشمي سنعود له بعد قليل
نؤكد من جديد على هذا العاجل رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي يقول انه سيتوجه الى
السودان فورا
نتابع مختلف وتطورات مع عطيه العيساوي
الباحث المتخصص في شؤون الافريقيه بمركز
الاهرام سيد عطيه اهلا بك معنا الكل يتابع
في الواقع هذه التطورات
وتداعياتها
وكيف سيكون الوضع مستقبلا خاصه النقطه
الملفته والتي راها البعض ايجابيه هي
الاتفاق على فتح مسارات امنه لخروج
المدنيين ولكن ما رصده بعض المراقبين في
داخل السوداني هو اطلاق نار مستمر ما الذي
نفهمه من هذا التطور
اعتقد ان المساله ليست بهذه السهوله
بحيث انه بمجرد الاتفاق يتم وقف اطلاق
النار لان القوات على الارض
يعني ظروفها الميدانيه تختلف ربما
مما يجعلها
تعدل او تسوي اوضاعها اولا قبل ان تنفذ
القرار وبالتالي يمكن اذا كانت هناك نيه
خالصه بالفعل
من الجانبين او من القيادتين
لاعطاء هذه الهدنه
للسماح للمدنيين بالخروج الى مناطق امنه
اذا كانت هناك نيه خالصه فسوف يتم التنفيذ
لكن اذا كان اذا لم تكن هناك نيه خالصه
وكان الامر مجرد ذر الرماد في العيون
والظهور بمظهر الحريص على حياه
امام الشعب وامام العالم فقط فاعتقد انه
لن يتم وقف العمليات العسكريه فيما يتعلق
بالعمليات العسكريه سنعود لهذه العمليه
العسكريه ولكن
الضغط على هذه الاطراف لمحاوله على الاقل
تثبيت هدنه سواء لدوافع انسانيه او كذلك
لمحاوله وضع كل الاطراف على طاوله واحده
لا نعلم ان كان الوقت لدى المبكر للحديث
على ذلك ولكن من الطرف القادر على الدخول
بوساطه حقيقيه للتاثير على هذه الاطراف في
هذا الوقت الراهن
يعني من تجربات السودان السابقه عندما تم
الاطاحه
بنظام الرئيس البشير
وتم الاتفاق بوساطه افريقيه
تعاون معها رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي
احمد
لاقسام السلطه بين المدنيين والعسكريين
استطيع ان اقول ان الاتحاد الافريقي
مدعوما بشخصيه كاريزميه مثل ابي احمد يمكن
ان يقوم بمثل هذا الامر الامر
الامر الاخر هو انه يمكن للجمع العربيه
تشكيل وفد من دول مؤثره ولها
نفوز وعلاقات قويه بالسودان مثل مصر
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ودوله امارات
العربيه المتحده ان يذهب هذا الوفد الى
الى الخرطوم
لاقناع الطرفين بوقف اطلاق النار والترتيب
للدخول في مفاوضات لحل الازمه سلميا يمكن
ايضا
التعاون من قبل الولايات المتحده
دول مثل النرويج التي لها مساعدات انسانيه
كبيره في السودان وغيرها
وبريطانيا وغيرها يمكن ايضا ان تساعد لكن
الامر يحتاج الى ان يصل
المبعوثون بالفعل الى الخرطوم وليس مجرد
اصدار مناشداته او اصدار تصريحات لانه لن
يتم الاجابه
قبل الطرفين عطفا على كلام حضرتك منذ قليل
كانت هناك اخبار مفادها بان رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي يقول انه سيتوجه الى
السودان في اقرب وقت هو يقول فورا بحسب
هذه التصريحات استاذ عطيه تفضل بالبقاء
معي ساعود لك بعد لحظات بعد ان نرصد
الاوضاع في داخل السوداني مع زمينه مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم سالم
تسمعني
ممتاز سالم كنا نتحدث في نشرات سابقه على
موافقات الطرفين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع على فتح ممرات امنه لخروج المدنيين
ولكن
مع بدء التوقيت يعني الان نتحدث الساعه
الخامسه بتوقيت السودان المفروض كان منذ
ساعه الساعه الرابعه بتوقيت السودان
كالمفروض يبدا العمل بهذا الاتفاق ولكن
اصوات اطلاق النار استمرت حدثنا عن الصوره
من عند كيف هي
صوره واضحه جدا بان هناك تجدد للاختلافات
في مناطق التي
نسميها في اليوم ونصف اليوم
اقصد يوم الليله مناطق الشده وهي منطقه
القياده العامه للجيش وكذلك مطار الخ
رطوم هذه المناطق الان تشهد
واحتدام للقتال لنرى
من هذه المنطقه
تتحدث لو سمحتي فقط لان الصوت تقطع تتحدث
عن استمرار الاشتباكات في مطار الخرطوم
تتحدث كذلك عن استمرار الاشتباكات مقر
القياده العامه طيب
ايضا لافت هنا ان
شده هذا
الكتاب ظهرت بشراسه بعد اعلان مهمه
يعني لا يفهم
لان صوت مشوش ساعود لك بعد لحظات حتى
تكتمل الصوره وافهم منك خاصه ونفهم كذلك
كيف هي التطورات ولكن مشاهدينا نشير الى
هذه الصور نحن نتابع
صور لسيطره الجيش على معسكر قوات الدعم
السريع في ولايه كردفان اذا هذه صور
بثها الجيش يقول فيها انه سيطر على مركز
الدفاع يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع نتابع هذه
الصور مشاهدينا
والجيش السوداني يقول انه سيطر على مقر
قياده الدعم السريع في قطاع كردفان بحسب
ما اورد طبعا الجيش السوداني ان كان هناك
صوت طبيعي نستمع لصوت طبيعي لهذه الصور
اليوم
تمكنا من السيطره
المواقع
كل المواقع المتمرد
في ولايه الجنوب كردفان في مدينه كادوغلي
والحمد لله الان كل المواقع في تحت
السيطره القواتنا المسلحه
وحقيقه
طوقنا هذه المواقع
بكل القوات
سواء كان الجيش
او الشرطه
واستقلت الفنون
حاربا وترق وراها عدد لا تقدر
ب 19 عربه
ومعظم عربات صالحه وايضا 18 فرد
وبما فيهم الدابد برتبه النقيب
والحمد لله
على اهلنا في ولايه الجنوب كورتوفان لان
قواتكم الان مسيطر بكل مواقع بتاع الدعم
السريعه المتمردين وايضا
مسيطرين على كل المواقع بتاع الحركات
المتفلته وباذن الله
تعوم سلام في ولايه جنوب كورتوفان ونحن
جاهزين وهذا هو موقع بتاع الدعم السريع
فيها كميه من المخازن يا مخازن التعيينات
وايضا بهذا القدر كانت هذه كلمه للجيش
السوداني اعلن فيها ليس فقط سيطرته على
مقر قياده الدعم السريع في قطاع كوردوفان
ولكن على كل نقاط التي كان يسيطر عليها
الدعم السريع في قطاع كوردفان كذلك هذه
الكلمه اللي هي الجيش السوداني اكد فيها
استيلاءه بعد سيطرته على كل هذه نقاط
استلاء على 19 عربه يقول بان اغلبها صالحه
للاستعمال يعتبرها غنائم حرب
يتحدث عن اعتقال 12 فردا يتبع لدعم السريع
اعتبر بان هذه التحركات هي حركات متفلته
من الدعم السريع اذا الجيش السوداني ينشر
صورا وبيان كذلك متلفز ويتحدث فيه عن
سيطرته على مجموعه نقاط كان يسيطر عليها
دعم السريع في كردفان اعود من جديد الى
استطلاع الاوضاع في الخرطوم مع سالم
الهاشمي زميلنا سالم اهلا بك معنا كنت
حدثنا عن استمرار الاشتباكات ولكن بايه
وتيره وباي ثقل
نعم اشتدت هذه الوتيره بعد اعلان هذه
الهدنه وليس في الخرطوم وحدها هذه الوثيره
ايضا امتدت الى ام درمان في سلاح
المهندسين الان ايضا هناك اشتباك عنيف في
منطقه في سلاح المهندسين اشتباك رغم هذه
الهدنه
ورغم اعلان هذه الهدنه الانسانيه ايضا
ان هناك ترحيب كان بهذه الهدنه الغريب
مبعوثه الامم
موافقه البهام
حتى حتى السابعه مساء
واكد انهم وافقوا على هذه الهدنه مع
الموافقه على هذه الهدنه الان نشهد
احتدام ايضا للقتال وارتفاع
بانه مع بدايه هذه الهدنه وكان المعارك
اشتدت اكثر من الساعات السابقه ولكن سالم
هل هذه الهدنه وان استمرت لبعض الوقت لا
اكثر هل مكنت بعض المدنيين من الخروج مثلا
بكل هناك مدنيين خرجوا الى الشوارع لقضاء
بعض الحوائج المهمه بالنسبه لهم مجموعه من
الاغراض المتعلقه بافطارات رمضان وغير ذلك
من احتياجاتهم الخاصه
يعني هناك حركه استطيع ان اقول ليس
الطبيعيه بالمعنى الكامل لكن الى حد ما هي
قريب من الحركه الطبيعيه ونحن نتحدث اسمح
لي ونحن نتحدث نشير الى هذه الصور
المباشره من الخرطوم هناك تصاعد لدخان
كثيف في الواقع في هذه المنطقه نحاول ان
نفهم اكثر المكان وما الذي يحدث من تطورات
في داخل الخرطوم هناك تصاعد لدخان كثيف من
خلال هذه الصور نتابعه وكان زميلنا سالم
الهاشمي منذ قليل افادنا ببعض التفاصيل
وتطورات وقال بان هذه الاشتباكات مستمره
رغم اعلان الهدنه ورغم ارتفاق الطرفين
سواء الجيش السوداني او الدعم السريع
والموافقه على هذه الهدنه ولكن الاشتباكات
استمرت بل واشتدت اكثر مع انطلاق هذه
الهدنه التي مكنت في بدايتها بعض المدنيين
من الخروج من اقتناء بعض الحاجات الاساسيه
ولكنها ما لبثت ان
عادت من جديد هذه الاشتباكات وبوتيره اقوى
اعود لك
لا اعلم ان كانت هناك استهدافات او ان كان
هناك اصوات
نستهدفات تسمعها لانه الصوره تقول بان
هناك دخان كثيف لا نعلم هذا المكان نحاول
ان نفهم اكثر نحاول ان نفهم اكثر هذا
التطور الاخير ولكن اعود لك هل لك بعض
المعلومات فيما يخص هذا الموضوع سالم
هذه المنطقه هي القياده العامه للجيشه
السوداني التي
تندلع منها يندلع تندلع منها هذا هذا
الدخان بكثافه الان
وهذه المنطقه
كانت قد اعلن او كان قد اعلن الجيش
السوداني قبل ذلك انه يسيطر عليها وايضا
تحدثت قوات الدعم السريعه انها تسيطر
عليها ثم جاء الجيش السوداني مؤكدا سيطرته
على كامل في هذا العام واكد فقط ان هناك
على تخوم هذه المنطقه توجد بقوات للدعم
السريع في هذه المناطق تقوم المناطق
الموجوده فيها
الدخان
وهذا هذا دخان كثير سامر طيب خليني اؤكد
بانك تؤكد لانه تشير بان هذه الصور التي
نتابعها الان مباشره من الخرطوم هي مقر
الدعم السريع
عفوا مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
التي ادعت في بدء الامر الدعم السريع
بانها سيطرت عليها فيما بعد قال الجيش
واكد بانه هو المسيطر عليها وبقي بعض
عناصر دعم سريع على تخومها ولكن هناك
تصاعد لدخان كثيف وشديد السواد فسر لنا
اكثر او وضح لنا اكثر هذه الصوره
نعم هو دخان كثيف ومصحوب بنيران هذا واضح
انه حريق حريق لشيء ما ربما يكون
يعني واحد من المباني اذا كنا نتحدث عن ان
هذه المناطق العسكريه
وربما اقول ربما يكون هناك مخزن للسلاح
مثلا او غير ذلك كل هذه الاحتمالات وارده
لكن هو دخان كثيف جدا كما نراه في الشاشه
الان ونحن تابع بعض الصور التي تاتينا من
مروي كذلك هناك صور مباشره من الخرطوم صور
من مطار الخرطوم صور اخرى كذلك وبعض
الفيديوهات لقوات الدعم السريع
فيديو اخر للجيش السوداني وكذلك القضارف
وماذا يحدث فيها بعد ما اطلعنا على تطورات
في اندرمان كذلك من خلال الكلمه للجيش
السودانيه الذي هي اكد بان الجيش السوداني
سيطر على كل النقاط التي كان يسيطر عليها
في ما قبل الدعم السريع طيب سالم ما الذي
يحدث في مطار مروي في الساعات الاولى من
هذه الاشتباكات كان هناك تركيز على هذه
المنطقه لا اعلم ان كانت وردتك بعض
الاخبار التي تضعنا في اطار التطورات من
هناك
ذكرنا في كل الانباء انه كل الانباء تقول
ان المطار مروي يسيطر عليه يسيطر عليه
الجيش السوداني الا مقر القياده لهذا
المطار وهذا ما اخذ به مراسل العربيه من
هنا
لكن مساله مطار مروي وربما واحده من
الامور التي تحدث بعض الخبراء العسكريون
ان الجيش السوداني يمرحل هذه
العمليه او هذه الحرب او نزع هذا الفسيل
كما يقول الجيش السوداني انهاء
تمرد ميليشيا كما وصفها الجيش السوداني
بانه يعني يقوم بهذه المراحل مرحله تلوى
الاخرى وربما مرحله مطار واحده من الملاحظ
من المراحل هناك
مرحله تواجد هذه القوات في مقر القياده
العامه للجيش في تخوف مطار الخرطوم الدولي
في الولايات في كل ولايه على حده
فربما يكون الجيش السوداني يقوم بتمثيل
هذه المراحل مرحله تلوى الاخرى ساعود لك
سالم في هذه النشره وفي نشرتنا القادمه
لمعرفه تطورات كل هذه الملفات ولكن ساذهب
او سابقى في الخرطوم مع الكاتب الصحفي
عمرو شعبان سيد عمرو اهلا بك معنا كنا
نتحدث عن الشبكات متفارقه البعض وصف او
هناك مخاوف في هذه المرحله من ان تحتد
وتيره هذه الاشتباكات وهناك الفزع من حرب
اهليه هل هذا وارد
حقيقتين الاشياء المؤسسه انا تصاعد عده
الاشتباكات تنزل بالتاكيد بان القادم اسوا
لكن
فكره الحرب الاهليه وتعتمد بالاساس على
تناقض المكونات الاجتماعيه وتسليحها
العكس تماما منذ اندلاع على الاحداث في
ساعات الصباح الباكر يوم امس في التاسعه
صباحا كان واضحا حجما الالتحام الجماهيري
للسودانيين مع بعضهم البعض حالات الاحتواء
والاستضافه التي يقوم بها الاسر السودانيه
فيما بينها وبين العالقين كثير من المشاهد
اليه تعكس على الدعم المستوى الخرطوم
المدينه التي يعتبر المدينه مصنوعه ناهجه
على المدن الطبيعيه
هل حضرتك تريد ان تقول بان هناك محاوله
لتحيد النفس عن هذا الصراع العسكري او بين
اقوى فصيلين عسكريين في داخل سوداني لم
تعد هناك قاعده شعبيه مهمه لكلا الطرفين
بتاتا بتاتا الحرب اصبحت مكروهه في
السودان من حيث المبدا المزاج الشعبي
للمجتمع السوداني او للشعب السوداني او
غالبيه الشعب السوداني بالضب من رؤيه
الدماء التي يتدفق بلا سبب
ما يحدث الان هنالك مخاوف على الارواح
هنالك احساس مشترك بالمصير الان السودانيه
كلهم كلهم في مختلف بقاع السودان اصبحوا
اصحاب تجربه مشتركه معناه جنوب السودان في
السابق من الحروب معناته جنوب كردفان
معاناته النيه للازرق معانته دارفور
معناته كل مناطق السودان الان اصبحت تجربه
مشتركه هذا الامر وحد الوجدان السودانيين
اذا بعضهم في كرههم للحرب وصانعيها
بالتالي لا توجد قاعده شعبيه للحرب
باستثناء باستثناء الحريصين على صناعه
الفوضى في السودان ليتسنى لهم اعاده عقارب
الساعه للوراء ومن ثم القفز للعوده للحكم
في السودان بعدما طاحت بهم الثوره الشعبيه
العظيمه في 11 ابريل هؤلاء هم فقط
ولكن ما اسميت حضرتك فوضى بعض المراقبين
قال بانه هذه الفوضى قادره ان تهدا مع
اولى خطوات الموافقه على
تهدئه لمحاوله تثبيت مسارات امنه غير انه
الاشتباكات استمرت هل لك بعض المعلومات
بعض التفاصيل تفسير لما حدث
اعلان الاتفاق على مساره امام مرات امنه
او مسارات امنه بالتاكيد تخرج معها
الخارطه لهذه المسارات الامنه بالتاكيد
تخرج معها الاليات التي سيتم من خلال
تحقيق فتح هذه المسارات الامنه الزمنيه
هذا واضح ولكن لماذا لم تسبت هذه المسامع
بعين اكمل فكره دعيني اكمل الفكره اعلان
ذلك كله يتعارض تماما مع اليات التنسيق مع
الامم المتحده بشكل مباشر وهو الامر الذي
لم يحدث لانه المتحده سوى الاتفاق لكن هذا
كله يتعارض مع الخطاب الاعلامي لكل طرف من
الاطراف بانه سيطر والطرف الاخر ينفي في
سياق الحرب الدعايه والاعلاميه المتبادله
بين الطرفين كل يدعي سيطرته على المناط
فتح الممرات الامنه يعني ان كل طرف سيفتح
في مناطق سيطرته بالفعل مناطق السيطره
بالفعل اذا فتحتها فيها مباراه امنه هذا
سيحدد مناطق سيطرتك الحقيقيه وليس التي
تدعيها اعلاميا اذا يتعار ض فتح الممرات
الامنه التي وافق عليها الطرفين اعلاميا
مع واقع الامور على الارض في كشف مناطق
سيطرتهم الحقيقيه مما يكشف حملتنا
الدعائيه والاعلاميه بالتالي الهدف
السياسي مقدم على العمل الانساني في تقديم
افهم من حضرتك وكانه هناك اصوات اطلاق نار
نعم نعم
حاليا كانت سلطه اطلاق نار في اي نقطه نعم
الصدى الصوت طبعا يتردد انا داخل
الاستوديو لكن هي دائما في مناطق تخوم
القصر الجمهوري او على محيط القياده
العامه حيث الدخان المتصاعد باللون الاسود
في هذه المناطق بالتاكيد اللي هو شرق
الاستوديو او شمال الاستوديو طيب سيد عمرو
تفضل بالبقاء معي ان كان لازال معنا
الاستاذ عطيه العيساوي سيد عطيه نزلت معنا
صحيح في هذه التغطيه المستمره على شاشه
العربيه طيب سيد اعطيها كنا نتحدث منذ
اشهر وحضرتك اكيد تعلم عن
نيه لدمج الفصيلين او على الاقل خلينا
نقول لدمج الدعم السريع داخل مؤسسه الجيش
ولكن بدنا اليوم نتحدث عن اقتتال بين اقوى
فصيلين عسكريين فدخل السوداني لم يكن
الموضوع مفاجئ لانه تصريحات سابقه هذه
التطورات ولكن ما الذي حدث بين هذه الفتره
وتلك بين
تصريحات بالدمج وصولا الى الاقتتال
طبعا انعدام الثقه الشديد بين القيادتين
قياده الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
ادى الى ان او دفع كلا منهما لحشد قوته في
مواجهه الاخر
فاتى
قائد الدعم السريع بقواته من دارفور الى
قاعده مروي مثلا نقلها نقل كثيرا منها
اليها وحشد قوات ايضا او افرادا
كثيرين مدعومين بالسلاح في الخرطوم
وجيش تحسب ايضا لهذا الوضع وبدا يعزز
قواته لحمايه المصالح العامه
ومواجهه هذا الحشد من قبل الدعم السريع
وكان من المتوقع في اي لحظه طبعا بعد هذا
الحشد من من هذا الطرف ومن ذاك الطرف ان
يند القتال لاي شراره بسيطه بمجرد
انطلاقها ومن هنا
يبدو يبدو وفقا لما ورد في الانباء وما
قاله جيش يبدو ان الدعم السريع اراد ان
يستبق الموقف بالسيطره على بعض المناطق
الحيويه لفرض ارادته
ومطالبه على قياده الجيش ولكن طبعا رد
الجيش ولكن كيف للدعم السريع ان يتمكن من
ذلك استاذ عطيه بمعنى ان الدعم السريع
نعلم بانه انطلق في البدايه او اسس على
كونه ميليشيا جنجويد فيما بعد صحيح بانه
تسلح ولكن ليس بقوه الجيش السوداني كيف
للدعم السريع ان يكون حاضر في الخرطوم ان
يكون حاضر في مطار الخرطوم في القصر
الجمهوري في محيط مقر القياده في دارفور
وكذلك في مروي
الدعم السريع
قوه لا يستهان بها
ونمت وتسلحت وتعززت قوتها تحت اعين السلطه
سواء في عهد البشير وبقرار منه او في عهد
سلطه ما بعد البشير
اقصد طبعا السلطه العسكريه
وحتى السلطه المدنيه خلال الفتره القصيره
التي تولاها
رئيس الوزراء عبد الله حمدو
قوات الدعم السريع تتكون من
عدد ضخم من الافراد كلهم مسلحون ومدربون
جيدا
وتم الانفاق عليهم بسخاء من
الاموال التي جناها الدعم السريع من اداره
مناجم الذهب
وانتشر الى درجه انه هناك ما بين 70000
الى الف انتشروا في كل المناطق
الاستراتيجيه التي يراوها
مهمه
للحفاظ على مكانتهم وانتزاع
المكاسب التي يريدون ان تزاعها هذا ادى
طبعا الى دفعهم ساعود لك الى هذه النقطه
لتستكمل
لا فقط لانه
ساعود لك لاستكمال هذه الفكره فقط لان
هناك عاجل يخص مصر تدعو للوقف الفوري
للعمليات العسكريه في السودان اذا
مشاهدينا نشير الى هذا الخبر كنا نتابعه
منذ قليل اسفل شاشه العربيه مصر تدعو
للوقف الفوري للعمليات العسكريه في
السودان وربما ساعود لك بخصوص هذه النقطه
استاذ عطيه بعد استكمال فكرتك الاولى كنت
تتحدث عن الدعم السريع وكيف تمكن من
السيطره على مختلف المناطق التي يتواجد
فيها
استاذ عطيه هل تسمعني
هل تسمعينني
دفعتهم كثره عددهم والاسلحه التي
بايديهم
خاصه الاسلحه الثقيله وايضا
العربات
لاندكروزر وغيرها من العربات التي ينصب
عليها تنصب عليها المدافع دفعهم الى شن
هذا الهجوم
مغرورين بانه يمكنهم السيطره على
مناطق معينه تلوي زراعه الجيش وهذا طبعا
لانهم يعتقدون ان الجيش ضعيف
مشتت في كثير من انحاء السودان التي تواجه
اضطرابات وعلى الحدود مع اثيوبيا وعلى
الحدود مع ليبيا ومع تشاد وكل هذا اغراهم
بانهم يمكن ان يفعله ما يريدون لكن لم
يضعوا في حسبهم طبعا ان هناك فرقا كبيرا
قواتهم وقوات الجيش هم ما بين سبعين الفا
الى 100 الف لكن الجيش حوالي 200 الف منهم
50 الفا في الاحتياط الجيش مسلح بالدبابات
والمدرعات والمدفعيه الثقيله والطائرات
والسفن الحربيه وكل هذا طبعا ليس للدعم
السريع قبل به ومن هنا اذا اذا امكن
الحفاظ على الطائرات والمطارات السودانيه
من الا يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع اعتقد ان
السلاح الجوي
سيشكل فارقا كبيرا في السيطره على الاوضاع
فيما يتعلق بمصر ساعود لك بعد قليل
لمناقشه هذه النقطه واعود كذلك للخبر
المتعلق بمصر ودعوتها للوقف الفوري
للعمليات العسكريه في السودان ولكن
ان نعلق على هذه الصور هي صور لمبنى
القياده العامه للقوات البريه السودانيه
في العاصمه الخرطوم قبل وبعد استهدافه
جراء الاشتباك وتظهر صور حجم الدمار
والحرائق التي لحقت بالمبنى اذا مشاهدينا
هذا المبنى الذي نتابعه قبل
وبعد ونلاحظ الدمار ونتائج استهداف هذا
المبنى على يسار الشاشه كيف كان قبل
الاستهداف وعلى يمين الشاشه بعد الاستهداف
اعود لك سيد عطيه لاستكمال الفكره كان لك
تعليق بسيط على الخبر المتعلق بمصر التي
تطالب بوقفي الشبكات
نعم مصر لم تطالب فقط بوقف الاشتباكات
فورا وانما ابدى الرئيس السيسي ايضا
استعداده
للوساطه في هذا النزاع هذه هذا هذه
المبادره
ومصر يعني خبيره بشان السوداني منذ عشرات
السنين
وتستطيع ان تفعل الكثير بشرط واحد وهو ان
يكون لدى الطرفين
قياده الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع استعداد
للاستماع للمبادره المصريه ومناقشتها
وابداء الملاحظات عليها
تعديلها اذا تطلبها الامر وبنيه خالصه لكي
يتم بالفعل وقف اطلاق النار الدخول في
مفاوضات اما اذا شك اي من الطرفين في
الاهداف من هذه المبادره كاني مثلا ان مصر
منحازه لهذا الطرف ضد هذا الطرف ان يدعي
ذلك اعتقد ان مثل هذه المبادره كما هي
مبادرات كثيره مثلا من الاتحاد الافريقي
او من الجامعه العربيه او من غيرها لن
يكتب لها النجاح نحن فقط نوضح باننا نتحدث
عن تصريحات عن دعوات لوقف الاقتتال لا
نعلم من بين كل هذه التصريحات ما هي التي
يمكن ان ترقى ان تكون مبادره حقيقيه
للتحقيق ابق معي استاذ عطيه العيساوي اعود
لك بعد قليل ولكن نرصد الاوضاع من مدينه
مروي مع نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا
الصوره واخر التفاصيل من عندك
نزار يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال بزمينا
نزار بقداوي اعود له بعد لحظات لاستطلاع
الاوضاع كذلك في مدينه مروي المهمه مدينه
مروي يتواجد فيها مطار هو مطار جد مهم حتى
انه يعتبر ميناء جوي او يسمى بالميناء
الجوي القادر على انه يربط بين دول
افريقيا اوروبا
ودول الخليجيه كذلك هذا المطار جد مهم
وشهد اشتباكات كبيره في ساعات الصباح
الاولى ربما سنعود بعد قليل لنزار بقداوي
من مدينه مروي للوقوف على كل هذه التطورات
والتفاصيل ولكن ساذهب للاستاذ عمرو شعبان
استاذ عمرو الكاتب الصحفي من الخرطوم هل
هناك او كما تقرا انت من خلال هذه
التطورات عاد نزار من جديد طيب ساعود لكم
استاذ عمرو نزار تسمعني
الصوره من عندك من مروي
الصوره هي معلومات الان نحن نحاول ان
نتاكد منها معلومات هي اوليه لكن نحن الان
في ثوره التاكيد لها
المعلومات المعلومه الاولى تتعلق بوصول
بعض
الاسرى الذين كانوا في ايدي قوات الدعم
السريع خرجوا من مطار مروي الدولي وهم
الان في طريقهم او وصلوا بالفعل الى
مستشفى مروي العسكري هذه معلومه الان
اوليه مصادر خاصه لنا
المعلومه الثانيه هي بان على المعلومه
الاولى وتقول نزار بانك توردها بحذر طبعا
حتى تاكد منها ولكن بحسب مصادر اوليه
صحيح بحسب مصادر اوليه تتحدث عن وصول اسرع
من الدعم السريع واصولهم لمستشفى مروي
للعلاج
اسرع من القوات المسلحه السودانيه كانوا
بقبضه قوات الدعم السريع داخل المطار تم
الافراج عنهم وتوجهوا الى المنطقه
العسكريه تقريبا ومن ثم الى مستشفى مروي
لمعالجه اصاباتهم ولمعرفه وضعيتهم الصحيه
هي معلومات اوليه سنحاول ان نتاكد منها
حتى نعطي الصوره كامله هذه هي الموضوع هذا
هذه النقطه الاولى بالنسبه للنقطه الثانيه
النقطه الثانيه هي ايضا معلومات اوليه نحن
نحاول ان نجتهد اكثر لمعرفه التفاصيل
هنالك نسبه مقدره من سيارات قوات الدعم
السريع يبدو انها خرجت الان من مطار مروي
الدولي بالاتجاهات الشرقيه هنالك منطقه
شبهي مفتوحه مطله مباشره على التلال جبليه
وعلى صحراء يبدو انها اثره ان تخرج من هذه
المنطقه او ربما يكون تكتيك في اطار هذه
العمليه العسكريه هنالك ايضا من يتحدث عبر
مصادر لكنها غير قاطعه معلومات قاطعه بان
النسبه كبيره الان من المطار اصبح في يد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه ايضا الدقائق
المقبله ستؤكد هذه المعلومات او تنفيها
لكن هي مجريات الاحداث تتلاحق بصوره
متسارعه بحكم العمليه العسكريه هنا في
مروي وهنالك في الخرطوم
فقط فقط لاعيد واذكر بهذه النقاط لو سمحت
للنزار تقول بانه بحسب بعض المصادر نوردها
او نورد هذه المعلومات بكل حذر لمشاهدينا
حتى تاكد من دقه هذه المصادر مطار مروي
سيطره عليه الجيش السوداني ولكن نتاكد
اولا من دقه وصحه هذه المصادر تتحدث كذلك
عن سيارات لدعم السريع فسر لنا اكثر هذه
النقطه كنت تتحدث من محاوله
يعني
هناك شيء يحضر فيما يخص الدعم السريع
خرجوا من ايه نقطه وهم متجهون الى اين
بطبيعه الحال الذي كان يوم الامس وحتى
الساعات السابقه مطار مروي كان محاصرا من
اتجاهات مختلفه
كانت هنالك نداءات من قوات الجيش السوداني
لقوات الدعم السريع
بامكانهم ان يسلموا واعتادهم واسلحتهم وان
يتعاملوا معهم وفق المعطيات التي دائما ما
تحدث خلال الاشتباكات والعمليه العسكريه
خلال الساعتين الماضيتين يبدو حسب ايضا
المعلومات بان السيارات تتبع لقوات الدعم
السريع اثرت ان تخرج من الجهاد التي لا
وجود فيها تقريبا لقوات الجيش السوداني هي
مناطق الضيقه للغايه تطل على مناطق جبليه
في قاعده مروي كل المناطق كانت محاطه
بوجود بالقوات لكن هذه النقاط يبدو انها
مطله على الصحراء او بعيده كل البعد عن
محاور الارتكاز للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
خ هذه القوات اتجهت الى مناطق يكون انها
شماليه او شرقيه نحو 40 سياره وبرفقتها
سياره اسعاف للمصابين والمرضى تحركت خارج
القاعده العسكريه ايضا المعلومات كانت
تؤكد بان خروج هذه
لا يعني كافه قوات الدعم السريع من المطار
تبقت نحو 60 او 65 سياره او اليه عسكريه
تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع المعلومه التي
اوردناها الان تؤكد بان قوات الدعم
السريعه الان اما انها خرجت بكلياتها من
المطار وانسحبت او انه تكتيك في ظل
العمليه التي ظلت مستمره حتى الان من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش القوات
اذكر من جديد بما اوردته لنا نزار بقداوي
مراسلنا من مدينه مروي هناك حديث عن خروج
ما يقارب الاربعين سياره من مطار مروي فهم
مراقبون هذا الموضوع بانه هناك عمليه بدء
اخلاء مطار مروي ولكن تؤكد لنا بانه بحسب
مصادرك دائما نزار هناك مجموعه اخرى من
السيارات او من الاليات التابعه للدعم
السريع تقدر باكثر من 60 اليه بقيت داخل
مطار مروي الخبر الثاني الذي اوردته منذ
قليل بحسب مصادرك طبعا ونورد هذا الخبر
حتى نتاكد من دقته ومن صحته هو ان الجيش
السوداني تمكن السيطره على اكبر مساحه من
مطار مروي في ظل كل هذا وفي ظل كل هذه
التطورات نزار كيف هو حال مدنيين
المدنيون بطبيعه حالهم وباوضاعهم الان
يعني على بعد نصف ساعه فقط من افطار رمضان
دعواتهم بان يسلم الله البلاد والعباد في
السودان وان يسلم مروي واهل مروي مما
يشاهدونه نهار هذا اليوم او خلال الساعتين
الماضيتين ايضا
رعبتهم جدا او اثارت مخالطهم اعمده الدخان
التي تمددت داخل قاعده مروي
له
مجددا فالمدنيين الذين اصيب منهم نحو خمسه
فقط ونحمد الله على هذه النسبه القليله
من المدنيين تعرضوا لشظايا توجهت من داخل
القاعه الى خارج القاعه تحديدا في المناطق
المحيطه بقاعده مروي الجويه تلقوا العلاج
اللازم داخل مستشفى مروي وهم الان باتم
الصحه والعافيه فيما يلي العسكريين او
القوات المسلحه السودانيه الاصابات في
حدود ال50 اصابه تم نقلها الى مستشفيين
الاول مستشفى مروي العسكري وهو مستشفى
مخصص للقوات المسلحه ولكن ايضا بامكان
المدنيين ان يتلقوا الدعم والعلاج في هذا
المستشفى والمستشفى الاخر هو مستشفى كريمه
يوجد على الضفه الاخرى من النيل عبر عبور
جسر كريمه في المدينه الاخرى ايضا هذا
المستشفى مجهز بامكانياته للتعامل مع
الجرحى والاصابات اعود لك بعد قليل نظام
بعد ان نفهم كذلك هذه التطورات التي
اورثتها هناك نقاط
مهمه لاخر التفاصيل من مدينه مروي من
المطار بالتحديد
نناقش كل هذا ونستطلع المزيد من التطورات
مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم الدكتور يعقوب عبد
الكريم نورين استاذ العلقه الدوليه
والاعلام دكتور يعقوب اهلا بك معنا هذه
التطورات الى اين
المبارك
والان يعني هنالك خطوه
عليها الشعب السوداني وهي اعلان القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع بانهم سوف
يسمحون بهدنى
وممرات امنه لاخراج المواطنين العزل
وتقديم العنايه الطبيه للجرحى والمصابين
انا افتكر به خطوه كويسه جدا جدا
مراقبون يقولون بانها خطوه جيده ولكن هذه
الخطوه بحسب ما وردنا صحيح ولكن دكتور
بحسب ما وردنا عن مراقبين في داخل
السوداني تم صحيح ولكن للشبكات استمرت هل
تعتقد بانه قد تستانف هذه الخطوه
هي بدايه جديد جيده ومؤشر جيد الى ان
هنالك اجتماع للصوت الدولي واجتماع لصوت
المبادرات التي تحدث في الداخل والخارج
وانا افتكر بخطوه ممكن تكون تمشي الجلوس
والتفاوض حول
العمليه السياسيه وسير العمل واخفق النار
لذلك بعد ذلك الناس يشوفوا للتفاوض كيفيه
ادارته والحاجه الثانيه برضو انه الان
الجهاز المخابرات العامه يقول لا تفاوض
ولا الا بعد تفتيح
وذلك يعني نحن نحن هذه التصريحات تبعد
الشقه ولا تغربها باي حال من الاحوال
وانما تظن انه كذلك اشياء كثيره
الان ولكن خطوه اللي هي سلامه الجرحى
والمصابين وتقديم العنايه الطبيه لهم يمكن
ان تكون خطوه في الطريقه الصحيح الى بعد
ذلك من الناس يمشي تفاوض او الفلوس يعقوب
لبدايه هذه الساعات ونفهم ما الذي حدث كنا
نتحدث عن محاوله تدخل بين الاطراف السودان
سواء الدعم السريع او الجيش السوداني
لاستكمال مراحل تطبيق الاتفاق الايطالي
نعلم بان هناك عدم توافق بين الطرفين دقلو
والبرهان مع حفظ الالقاب طبعا ما الذي حدث
حتى يتحرك الدعم السريع باتجاه كما يقول
مراقبون في داخل السوداني اشعار فتيل ازمه
جديده
الازمه الدعم السريع لم يكن يجري حتى ماذا
السياسيه بنائب الرئيس الفريقون محمد
حمدان دقله والتقت كذلك في الفريق اول
البرهان
ولكن قبل الاجتماع تم تم
الهجوم والى على معسكرات ودعم السريع في
المدينه الرياضيه وفي صوبا
وبالتالي كانوا هم يردون على هذا الامر
ذلك دائما اعز جهاز
الدكتور صحيح ولكن ولكن الدكتور يعقوب
الجهه المقابله تقول بانه
عمليه محاوله السيطره على عناصر الدعم
السريع اتت بعد ان حاولوا ان يتواجدوا في
مناطق هم بالاصل لا يمكن ان يتواجدوا فيها
هم يحاولون ان يتوسعوا في محيط بعض
المراكز
وبالتالي من ادق
بعيد وفي المدينه الرياضيه من زمن بعيد
الجيش اعلم ذلك كلها الناس يعلم ذلك
يعني ليس
مبرر الى العاصمه القوميه يعني هذا ليس
امرا بالساهل الحرب ليست ماء ليست
فسحه من يعني ولهذا طرح صحيح ولهذا صحيح
ولهذا طرح السؤال لماذا محاوله السيطره
بالسلاح لماذا لم يتم استدراك الموضوع
لانك تقول بان هناك لقاء كان مقرر يوم
السبت قبله بساعات تطور الموضوع الى
العسكره وليس الى محاوله التفاوض ما الذي
حدث خلال هذه الساعات هذا السؤال
[موسيقى]
الجيش لا يدري ورئيس الدعم السريع لا يدري
اذا سمعت التصريحاتهم
معناه القوه
الفريق البرهان ووضع في
الامر معروفه في في في
السودان يعني معروفين يفعلون هذه الاشياء
دائما
ولكن باي هدف يتحرك البرهان مع حفظ
الالقاب اي هدف
الواقع ولكن اسمح لي دكتور يعقوب اسمحلي
فقط لافهمك لما تقول لي بانه قائد قوات
الدعم السريع لا يعلم بهذه او على الاقل
كيف
بدات شراره هذه الاشتباكات وسيد البرهان
كذلك همم لا يدري بحسب قراءتك الموضوع
بحسب على الاقل ما قراته من تصريحاته من
الذي يعلم من الذي خطط من الذي اعطى الاذن
ببدا رفع السلاح
قلت لك ان هنالك عناصر داخل الجيش التي لا
تريد العمليه السياسيه ان تستمر ولا تريد
لان يكون هنالك توافق وحكومه مدنيه
انهما متعودين على الانجابات العسكريه
والصعود على ظهر الجيش السوداني كل
الانقلابات الح
سره المد
ني بمباشره بدون علم الجيش وبدون علم
غائده الدعم السريع
الجيش
عشان كده القصه دكتور صحيح افهم افهم كلام
حضرتك ولكن مراقبون يقولون بان الموضوع لا
يتعلق
بالجانب المدني او بالفصيل المدني الموضوع
يتعلق اساسا بكيفيه دمج الدعم السريع داخل
مؤسسه الجيش
هذا هذه هي النقطه اللي حصل عليها الخلاف
قائد الجيش
فقد كان الاختلاف على المده المده الجيش
قال سنتين الدعم 20 سنه الوصفه
وافق الناس في هذا الامر يا سيدتي حتى لا
يلي الاخرون عنقا الحقيقه لكن هذه ليست
المشكله ليست المشكله
اذا هل هذا مضر لقياده حرب اذا كان يمكن
كان هذا الامر يؤجل الان الكثير من
القيادات في الجيش يتكلموا عن انه المساله
كان يمكن ان تكون في الحكومه منتخذه اذا
ما الذي يمنع انه اجل قضيه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري الى الحكومه المنتخبه ونمضي في
الاجراءاتنا السياسيه في الحكومه مدنيه
وتقييم
مؤسسه في التحول الديمقراطي طيب خليني
اسال في هذه النقطه الاستاذ اعطيها
العيساوي صحيح طيب اسمح لي ان انتقل
الاستاذه عطيه العيساوي الباحث المتخصص في
شؤون الافريقيه استاذ عطيه هل الموضوع
يتعلق بخلاف عسكري عسكري او الموضوع اكبر
من ذلك وكما يقول الدكتور يعقوب هناك
عناصر تعمل داخل الجيش دون معيه قياده
الجيش
يعني في اعتقاد يا ان الخلاف اساسا خلاف
عسكري ما بين العسكر وبين الدعم السريع
خلاف على نقطتين اساسيتين المده التي
يراد خلالها
دمج الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه
القوات المسلحه تريد عامين على الاكثر
بينما الدعم الشريف قال عشر سنوات على
الاقل
وهذه طبعا مده طويله جدا
تدل يدل هذا الخلاف على انعدام الثقه بين
الطرفين لان الدعم السريع يخشى انه اذا تم
دمجه بسرعه
بينما لا يضمن ليس هناك ما يضمن لهم
البقاء في مناصبهم والحصول على حقوقهم في
الرتب العسكريه وغيرها جعلهم يطالبون بان
تكون المده عشر سنوات على الاقل الخلاف
الاخر طبعا هو
المناصب المناصب
المناصب
المناصب العسكريه يعني هناك
بالتاكيد قواعد
وبروتوكولات تسير على اساسها القوات
المسلحه ويتم على اساسها تشكيل الهيكل
العام للقوات المسلحه وفقا للاعراف
الدوليه اذا اذا كان مثلا مع احترام
الفريق
دجله
بانه هو نائب يعني حصل على رتبه الفريق
وهو نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
نائب رئيس او نائب القائد العام للجيش كل
هذا رغم انه لا يحمل شهاده عسكريه وليس
خريج ك عسكريه عندما يطالب بهذه بهذا
المنصب خلال النظام الجديد عند عمليه
الدمج سيثير ذلك سائره القاده العسكريين
الذين لهم ثلاثون عاما او اقل او اكثر في
العمل العسكري وحصلوا على الكثير من
الدورات العسكريه فضلا عن انهم خريجون
لكليات عسكريه
هذه المرحله هي سبب الخلاف مدعومه طبعا
عفوا عفوا عفوا مدعومه طبعا
بانصار كل طرف في في السلطه المدنيه او في
الاحزاب الاحزاب والجماعات المجتمع المدني
هناك من يؤيدون
دجله دعم قائد الدعم السريع وهناك من
يؤيدون البرهان قائد الجيش ورئيس مجلس
السياده كل له هدفه من ذلك
الذين يؤيدون دجله
يخشون ان يسمح البرهان وفقا لاعتقادهم
بعوده فلول النظام السابق الى مراكز
السلطه
وامور اخرى والذين يؤيدون الجيش يؤيدونه
وفقا خوفا على مصالح البلاد وايضا
خشيه ان يتعمق خشيه ان يتوحش ان اسال
الدعم السريع المكون المدني يعني حضرتك
تقول بانه او تلخص المشكله بانها محور حول
نقطتين النقطه الاولى هي عمليه الدمج التي
اختلف عليها الطرفان النقطه الثانيه هي
بعض الامتيازات التي كان ينتفع منها الدعم
السريع ومع عمليه دمج يمكن ان يخسرها ولكن
اين المكون المدني من كل هذا
المكون المدني طبعا هناك كثيرون اعتقد هذا
هناك كثيرون يعني فرحونا
بانهم كما يقول المثل بان العسكريين كما
يقول المثل وقعوا بعض يعني حارب بعضهم
بعضا وانه لابد ان
احدهم سيهد قوه الاخر
ويقلل منها لكن طبعا الغالبيه العظمى من
السودانيين بما فيهم جماعات المجتمع
المدني والاحزاب السياسيه تقشى من ان يؤدي
ذلك الى
يعني
الى
انهيار القوات المسلحه او على الاقل
اضعافها في مواجهه مخاطر خارجيه كثيره مثل
الخلاف مع اثيوبيا على الحدود وايضا
الارهاب وغيرها من
المخاطر التي تحدث بالسودان مثل من دول
افريقيا
الكثير من الشخصيات بما فيهم رئيس حزب
الامه السوداني
دعوه الى وقف اطلاق النار بسرعه حاولوا
التدخل رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد الله
حمدوك ايضا دعوات وتصريحات في هذا الاطار
من اطراف عديده ولكن اسمح لي لان وقت هذه
الساعه انتهى تماما اود شكرك جزيل الشكر
اعطيه العيساوي الباحث المتخصص في شؤون
الافريقيه بمركز الاهرام الشكر كذلك موصول
لضيوفنا واسسوا معنا هذه الساعه عمرو
شعبان كاتب صحفي من الخرطوم الدكتور يعقوب
عبد الكريم استاذ العلاقات والاعلام وكذلك
زملائنا سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم ونزار
بقداوي من مدينه مروي اشكركم جزيلا الشكر
هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن تغطيه العربيه
مستمره مشاهدينا لكل التطورات التي يعيشها
السودان بعد قليل زميلتي ليال الاختيار
تستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه يبقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات